ساخنه هي الحدود السوريه التركيه وتقبل كل
الاحتمالات خصوصا في مناطق سيطره ما يعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه شمال شرقي سوريا
مع استمرار الضربات التركيه لمواقع تلك
القوات تواصل اطراف دوليه تحركها لايجاد
حلول او بدائل اما تعتزم وانقر القيام به
من عمليه عسكريه تضمن فيها امن حدودها
الجنوبيه كما تقول
الموقف الابرز كان من موسكو التي تحدث
وزير خارجيتها ان عزمي بلاده منع اي
اعتداءات على وحده اراضي سوريا وهو تصريح
يشير الى ما يعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
التي تراها اطراف اقليميه ومحليه انها ذات
مشروع انفصالي يرمي الى خلق من طاقه
يحكمها اكراد سوريا رغم ان تلك القوات لم
تعلن صراحه عن مشروع تنفصل فيه لمنطقه عن
الاراضي السوريه وان تمتعت تلك المنطقه
بما يسمى اداره ذاتيه
عاد الافراد الى الواجهه اتفاق ايضا
المبرمه بين تركيا وسوريا عام 98 واتفاق
يمنح تركيا حق مطارده منتصفهم بالارهابيين
داخل اراضي سوريا بعمق خمسه كيلومترات كما
يمنحها حق اتخاذ ما تراه مناسبا لضمان
امنها القومي
في الاتفاق ارضيه مناسبه لاستئناف الحوار
بين تركيا والنظام السوري لحل قضيه امن
الحدود بين البلدين مع اخذ مخاوف في تركيا
بعين الاعتبار
قد يحمل خطاب الافراد على انه طرح من
زاويه جديده لمقترح قدمته موسكو سابقا بان
تحل قوات النظام السوري محل ما يعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه عند الحدود المشتركه مع
تركيا بالنظر الى رفض تلك القوات المتكرر
للمقترح الروسي لتجنب العمليه البريه
التركيه المحتمله يقول قائد ما يسمى قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه انها انتزعت السيطره
على المنطقه بعد معارك ضد تنظيم الدوله
وان تفكيكها غير وارد حتى مع الوصول الى
حل سياسي في سوريا
مؤثر في مشهد شمال شرق سوريا مع ارسالها
وفدا الى انقرا يبحث خيارات هذا الملف
اما واشنطن الداعم الرئيسي لما يعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه فقد جدد منسق لاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس امنها القومي جون
كيربي جدد رفض بلاده لاي عمل عسكري شمال
شرق سوريا وعلى الارض اعلن التحالف الدولي
لقتال تنظيم الدوله والذي تقوده الولايات
المتحده التزامه بدعم من سماهم شركاءه في
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه لايجاد منطقه امنه
ومستقره فضلا عن استئناف في تفسير دوريات
امنيه مشتركه مع تلك القوات
فكيف سيكون وضع شمالي شرقي سوريا خصوصا ان
تركيا منحت مهله زمنيه لم يحدد اجلها لبدء
عملها العسكريه البري الرامي لطرد
المسلحين الاكراد